[Applause]
there's a lot of people out there that
call themselves artists
but there's no bad art
the beauty's in the eye of the beholder
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chainsaw carving has a certain element
of theater to it
it's kind of a performance art
you're creating a sculpture in a short
enough period of time
it's entertaining
so i moved here when i was 16 from lake
quinault which is over on the olympic
peninsula
which is logging country which is wood
and chainsaws and growing up with that
whole lager culture
i bought this place it was a functioning
sawmill and then it kind of came a
hillbilly research and development
artistic center
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm a voracious reader sometimes i'll
read a book and then i'll go out and
carve the characters
out of my head
[Music]
the chainsaw has such a you know texas
massacre
tearing down the rain forest destruction
type of tool
well here you are creating a thing of
beauty with a tool that's known for
you know making bone and flesh into a
fine red mist
[Music]
i'm a second generation to my mom and
her brothers
who were some of the first people to do
it
and you know grew up with it and
became a carver because it seemed normal
[Music]
and then i started doing the chainsaw
carving competitions
so i threw myself into them when i was
in my early twenties and got involved
with anything to do with this any show
that came up
that's what i would do and go i wheel a
deal
entrepreneurship is the last refuge of
the troublemaker
what i like to do is i find out how much
money you have and then i don't charge
anymore
[Laughter]
the competitions of course are where
everyone gathers together
a lot of us are drifters or
itinerant or people like me that live on
back roads
a handful of us we had a guild and a
club and we
created a nucleus of a group of uh
chainsaw carver dedicated to making
the art form more well-known and
respected
which is the hardest right part
it's uh hard to make a living at it
raise kids and
pay your bills
anyone's an artist i mean kids start out
as artists until someone tells them
they're not
and if someone has enough guts to get
alongside the road and set up and do it
it takes a tremendous amount of courage
to make something and then go out and
try to sell it
there's a lot of different ways of
making a living at it
[Music]
the best way to make a good living out
though is to have a wife with a good job
[Music]
i wonder what it it's probably something
that could pass
us through their digestive system and
now we can mock them
i'm guessing
[Music]
you